Speaker 1: So we spoke before the break about
Fox News in the aftermath of the buffalo mass
shooting terrorist attack, bringing on a guest
and Jon Scott pushing on the guests. The idea
that i don't know, since video games have
become so realistic and violent, we've seen
more violent shootings and we've already talked
about the academic work on the link between real
world violence and video games, and there is no
such link. Now, I want to show you something else
that Fox News did in the immediate aftermath
of the Buffalo shooting, where it's a domestic
white guy born here, allegedly with three weapons,
went and targeted black people, deliberately went
and targeted black people. Fox News hosted a
segment where they made the case that we really
need to be worried about the Hispanic terrorists
coming through the US-Mexico border that we we
just had this incident. And you're talking about
something which is not actually a statistical
issue. I'll explain. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: He is not the secretary of
homeland security's the secretary
of homeland insecurity, because our.
Speaker 1: Country, by the way, this is
Tom Homan from the Heritage Foundation,
a right wing think tank.
Speaker 3: Safe because like last month,
they admitted the arrest of 42 people on the
screening database, terror screening database.
There has been over 700,000 known got away since
Joe Biden became president. How many of them were
on the terror screening database are in the
country right now? You're not going to tell
me. Out of 700,000 with 161 different countries,
many that sponsor terrorism, not a single person
came across that border not get arrested. That
came this country do us harm. This is a national
security issue of huge proportions.
I've done this for 35 years, Lawrence.
I've never been more concerned about the safety
of this nation. Diane, under this administration,
the secretary please be impeached on day one
when the Republicans take back Congress. And
I told them that last week when I met with them.
Speaker 1: Yeah. What a powerful declaration from
Tom home. And now let's let's remember, we know
a lot about immigrants to the United States. Now,
is it impossible that they always say you've
got Muslim terrorists coming through the border
disguised as Hispanics coming here and doing
terror? Well, we know about the terror attacks
here, and it's mostly American born white men that
do the the terror attacks in the United States. So
let's just think it through. We know that if you
take three groups of American born individuals,
legal immigrants to the United States and
illegal immigrants to the United States,
the group that commits crime at the highest rate
is those born here in the United States. Now,
it makes perfect sense. We shouldn't hear that
and say that. That doesn't make any sense. David,
why would it be why? Why would that? It seems that
the immigrants should be the ones committing more
crime. Why? Why, if you are here undocumented,
you're aware that any kind of police interaction
in some states where they have show me your
papers laws, even just a driving infraction
could end up with you getting deported. You
know, your status here is undocumented. So
you are incentivized not to be on the radar of
law enforcement in a way that a legal immigrant
or a a natural born American would not be.
Natural born Americans know if I get caught
speeding, it doesn't matter what state it's in,
I'm not getting deported. Whereas an undocumented
immigrant knows that that is a possibility,
that's an incentive for undocumented immigrants to
actually behave even better. And they do. And they
do. Legal immigrants as well. Legal immigrants
also commit crime at a lower rate than domestic
natural born citizens of the United States. And
it makes perfect sense. So there is like two or
three different layers here. One is, of course,
that they're just wrong about this idea that the
the major emitters of crime here are foreign born.
They're not by rate. Right. Okay. So that accounts
per capita for the fact that there are more
natural domestically born individuals
in the country. And number two,
without a shred of irony, an 18 year old
U.S. born white guy targets black people,
kills ten and injures three. 11 of the 13 in
total are black. And Fox runs with video games
are violent. And we've really got to do something
about terrorists coming over the southern border.
Now, they're being born here. They're being born
here. So there's sort of a question as to whether
people like Tucker are going to cool it
with some of the great replacement stuff
because it's so directly linked to the shooting
over the weekend. And this is this is the clip
I showed you is from the hard news side of
Fox News. So it's going to be quite a scene.